foreign
and if my 12 year old is so focused on a
particular thing a video game I'm the
parent it's my job to intervene here's
the dopest thing about Electronics
there's a button on the side and it says
off
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney's show
I've had way too much caffeine today man
coffee with the family full kill cliff
and now some more coffee I don't even
know why I just I'm just let me see how
far we can push this engine today and
about noon you may see me face down in a
field somewhere my body just said we're
done we're done hey but we're so glad
that you have joined us
for a a mental health podcast where uh I
start the show by telling you I'm not
doing so great hey um if you want to be
on what is clearly the greatest mental
health in marriage and relationship
podcast of all time
um give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-3291
or go to John deloney.com ask a s k hey
real quick somebody on the internet's
pointing this out and I can't believe I
just blew it
um
on the episode we did I don't know a
couple days ago now on uh seasonal
seasonal affective disorder sad right I
talked about getting a light table and I
also I could I just completely whiffed I
use this little device it's called the
valky v-a-l-k-e-e I think it's out of
Sweden or something
it's a my wife calls it's one of my
gadgets it just goes in a Trey she's I
don't even know what this stuff is and I
think it's all Shenanigans this is
incredible I love it
um here's what it is you can get
sunlight inside your body through your
eyes that's the main portal you can get
through your skin
um you can also get it through your ears
and so if you click it you can see it
lights up really bright and you just put
in your ears like headphones and you go
about your morning and it lasts for
about 12-15 minutes and I do several
rounds of this I don't get one penny
from this this organization I don't know
who this organization is but I do use
this thing I don't even know if it works
Beyond
um psychosomatic stuff but I love it and
I use it all the time and I feel like it
gives me a great boost in the morning it
kind of brightens things up and so
anyway I forgot to mention that somebody
reached out and said hey I thought you
used that thing and I was like I did and
I completely blew it in that segment so
there you go
um also one other thing that I screwed
up
um Lane Norton called me he called me on
the phone the other day and he said hey
I listen to your podcast
um and you told somebody something that
was wrong like inaccurate and I'm just
calling you out from this friend to
friend and scientist to scientist I'm
calling you out and so we talked through
it and he is right he's right here's
what he told me
um I gave some guy a guy was calling in
about nutrition and about how he runs to
certain foods and things when he's
feeling certain ways and I told him in
my house
I have to go with the scorched Earth
approach I cannot have certain things in
my home
um because I can't control myself and I
even pointed to some genetic testing
I've had done that said I have something
called a cookie jar Gene that makes it
very hard whatever
in Lane
um Dr Norton said hey and he used my
language against me as a good scientist
does
he said
I believe it's just a story you're
telling yourself
that you are unable to you are powerless
in the face of a bag of cookies
I and he went on to say I think you're
stronger than that and I think you could
practice self-control in a way
that would
um lead you to not have to live your
life fearful of certain foods or fearful
of certain moods oh my gosh I should be
a rapper moods and foods but like you
don't have to live your life that way
and when he said it it just kind of
washed over me I was like that's exactly
what I tell people about anxiety and
about depression and about
um I don't know how to have hard
conversations in my marriage and and sex
intimacy has become too weird to talk
about even
I tell people hey that's just a story
you're telling yourself and there's a
path forward and so
um he talked through some of the
research around he's right he was right
and so um to the gentleman that I gave
the wrong advice to
um I think there's a season this is this
is me Bridging the Gap here I do think
there's a season for scorched Earth I
think there's a season for overcoming
Addiction on some of these things and
there's things like alcohol like I'm I'm
never gonna have this for the rest of my
life
but I also think that we all myself
going first need to be cognizant of
Stories We Tell ourselves about things
we can and cannot do
and if we find something in our life I
just can't do that I just can't I just
can't
can I truly just not maybe if you're
five six you're not ever gonna dunk
maybe that's true
but if it's I just I just can't hear
another story but really I just can't
have that conversation with him because
that really
I just can't be around gummy candies
because I can't control myself so this
morning I walked in somebody bought me a
bunch of gummy candies and it was on my
desk
and I looked at it and I thought I
really want these for breakfast
and then I let that feeling pass and
then I went about my day and I thought
freaking Norton he's right
it's the benefit of having brilliant
friends who will call you out iron
sharpens iron thanks brother Norton and
uh all right let's go to Stephanie in
Ventura Ventura Boulevard California
what's up Stephanie
hi Dr John how are you I'm good what are
you doing
good I'm currently sitting in my car
alone
is that is this a good thing or a bad
thing it's a great thing I I'll I'll
tell you a little bit about me but I'm a
moment are you a mom of small kids you
have yeah five under six yes
so there's a little back story to like
my question today and basically it's
five children Hey listen I don't know
what your backstory is we just take a
minute
you're all by your Hey listen here's the
deal if you just want to hang up the
phone right now and just sit there
quietly for 20 minutes that that will
probably be more beneficial than
anything I'm going to say to you this
morning just great
wow five kids under six
yeah
okay good for you all right let's hear
the back story let's do this
class are twins and they just turned one
because you know what why not why not
you know what hey here's what I love you
and your husband were like
yeah yeah let's have one more and he was
like I I don't know if I can do this or
you were like that one of you which one
was it oh him for sure okay he's like I
don't
and he thought
for her I'll do one more tell me about
tell me about the conversation when you
were like so plot twist
how did that conversation go well the
plan was to have six so that was the
plan and then we had our first two a
year apart and then our third we gave it
a little bit of a three-year buffer and
so with my with our fourth I was like
let's just do it again we've done that
we can handle that
and
um then surprise to two more beautiful
babies came if you
how many diapers are in your home right
now used and unused
oh Lord knows I don't know there has to
be a thousand I have no idea
it was wild
hey God bless you dude yeah I don't know
what to say man God bless you
all right so how can I how can I how can
I I don't know what I can offer you and
you haven't even asked your question yet
but go for it
well I'm just finding that having so
many kids so quickly has kind of caught
up to me in really in every way
um but I'm just finding that a lot of my
day is full of other people's needs and
um somebody asked me the other day like
what do you like to do for fun and all I
could say was sleep it was like I'm so
sad I don't even know no there's nothing
sad about that at all
um it's like John Mayer wrote a new song
called your body is a jungle gym right
you've just got yes kids all over people
all over you hey and by the way they're
one now right your your twins are fully
one
yes okay so his husband started like
raising the eyebrow like hey
uh
uh see
you you are never your own you're never
your own it listen
if the if the most
erotic fantasy you could summon right
now combined with the most realistic
physical and mental health things you
could summon and you put them all in one
big jar and shook it up what would come
out is just sleep right yeah I mean
that's like if he came in was like hey
you want to turn the lights down low
you'd be like yep and I'll be asleep in
eight seconds so that that honestly
doesn't
relieve yourself I mean it's like give
yourself peace okay you are that's the
goal you're you're everywhere and you're
just it's winter and so you gotta wear a
coat right it just is it just is six
under six or five under six
um
here's here's a here's what I think well
here's what I've seen help a lot okay
there's three three kind of bullet
points I would attach to life two of
them are relatively easy they're
uncomfortable but they're easy the third
is really challenging okay the first one
is be very clear about the reality of
this season
it just is
it's not fun it's so lovable and
exciting and all of that it's the best
worst time
and I want to free you from the moments
you're like
I hate everybody and your husband walks
in and you just look at him and say I
hate you the most and you just want to
go run screaming into the snow
are you in California so you don't have
that you want to go run screaming into
the ocean right those that's okay
you're not a bad mom because you want
your kids just just to shut up you're
not a bad moms because you want your
kids dick can you just go away so I can
you know what I want to do here's what I
want to do I want to go to the bathroom
all by myself
I want to wipe with nobody staring at me
that's what I want I want that more than
anything right that's okay I want you to
know you're not a bad mom okay you're
not a bad mom okay
um be very clear about the reality of
the season and that leads to number two
you haven't done this in a while
and you're at a point now where your
kids are out of I don't see survival
mode right they still have to have to
have to have a mom right but you know
the difference between like a
one-year-old and a five day old right
totally
um you got to be very very clear about
what you need in this season
and my guess is
um you have been living with a very with
a scarcity mindset there's only this
much time and there's this many kids and
so that question seems absurd it's
insane right away
um you've run long enough without any
Oxygen
and if you don't make a shift at some
point to put your health and wellness at
the center of this thing this ship just
runs out of gas
or it runs a ground right I'm mixing my
metaphors the truck runs out of gas so
asking yourself being very specific okay
for the next four weeks what do I need
and that is going to dictate your budget
that's going to dictate what y'all spend
money on it's going to dictate what you
end up asking your husband to do or what
support you need we need to hire a
housekeeper I'm going to ask Mom to come
visit for a few months like what do you
need and let's do this on a 30-day
increment
and let's get in the habit of asking her
okay what do I need right now and you
have to hear me say the greatest gift
you can give your kids
is to speak your needs out loud and give
other people the opportunity to help you
meet those needs
okay even if that's hiring a high school
kid to come over and just be in the
house while you take a two-hour nap
can you imagine how awesome a two-hour
nap would be we do have a nanny that
does help there you go so let's be super
clear about what we need sometimes it's
just when you hire nanny in the in your
situation it's just like I just whatever
I need help with it let's be real real
clear okay and this leads to number
three
this is the I think the big the big
thing happens to all of us happened to
me with one kid happened to me with two
kids and you have a thousand kids and
it's happening to me too
I just kept imagining my life as it was
before I had kid number one
and I tried to just insert the new kids
into that world
in that world before I had kids my wife
and I could just have sex whenever we
wanted to we could spend money on pretty
much whatever we wanted to we could just
travel whenever we could just do
whatever we wanted
because we're in a glitch in The Matrix
we had grown-up jobs and we had no kids
and so I didn't know at the time but we
had very limited responsibility
and I kept trying to
just insert kids into that world and I
never stopped to realize that everything
about my world had changed
and so there's something about exhaling
and getting out of the house for a day
or half a day and you sound like that's
insane and cool man we can do extra
pumping and storing for a while you and
your husband go away for half a day and
you have to reimagine your life because
it's new now
and if he's still waiting for hit that
crazy fun girlfriend wife that he had
before and if you're still wanting to
get back to whatever that phrase if we
can just get back to if I can just get
to that is a recipe for disaster in your
relationship
yeah I actually I actually think we're
doing honestly almost the opposite like
oh we could just get to the three-year
Mark three years been like our magic
number for our kids like okay we could
just get to three years like we'll be
able to leave the house again or like
not be run by Naps there is that I mean
there's definitely markers right you're
running a marathon you're like dude if I
can just get to mile five up that big
hill then miles five through seven are
downhill there's there's definitely a
component to that what you leave out of
that equation is oh then we can finally
get to that if we can just get everybody
to three and you don't understand what
life is gonna be like when you have a
nine-year-old
right and that's a whole other set of
challenges right and then when when your
nine-year-old turns 12 and is like he
dumped me and now we got a whole other
set right so you're always going to be
shuffling and moving and then what
happens is if you keep waiting for the
next milestone
like I worked in colleges for 20 years
the number of parents who come and
they're just they're they are wide-eyed
what just happened my kids are gone I
just dropped off my last kid and we kept
waiting for well then they get to high
school and then we'll be able to and
then when they get to and then now
they're just gone and so I would
encourage you to
reimagine your life full of
one-year-olds everywhere
and our life right now is not a life
conducive to going out unless we have
seven to eight babysitters here to help
out right
um and that means that means the nights
we go out they're going to be very very
special
and that means they're going to be
intentional on the bottom and that means
we're going to be gross about them we're
going to text each other a week out and
be like ew ha date coming up because
we're that's how intentional we have to
be because this is our new world in the
world we could just be like dude we got
a Bonus let's just go get steak that
world's over right now it's over and we
can be sad about it but it didn't exist
here's our new world here's what dates
are going to look like we have to still
go on them here's what romance is going
to look like romance might be just
holding hands and watching the office
till you doze off
romance oh honey you want to get me hot
and bothered go change diapers in the
middle of the night just once a week
just right I just I won't be able to
breathe I'll be so hot and bothered but
I'll be asleep and you won't know it so
like it's reimagining your life as it is
not just white knuckling it until you
get to some magic Milestone because the
milestones
man they they
you get one Milestone here but you're
off to the races on another one and you
just never think you can stop I will say
this when all of your kids are able to
go to the bathroom on their own and get
in and out of the shower on their own
that is pretty awesome not gonna lie
it's pretty amazing
looking forward to it like right now I
have a like I'm six-year-old and 12 year
old I can just say y'all go shower and
they do and I can just stare off into
space it's pretty awesome I'm not gonna
lie okay and I haven't wiped another
human's butt in a while so it's that's
pretty awesome I'm not gonna lie that is
a milestone but don't miss the
one-year-old years waiting until they
become three-year-old years because
you're gonna wait until they become 10
year old years and then they're gonna
leave right be and be in it with them
um and most importantly be in it with
your husband okay
yeah but
do you just ever sit and weep just cry
oh all the time
have you uh do you have a group of women
that you can text and talk and say am I
going crazy
FPU yeah
that sounded like shenanigans
one okay
and can you tell that person everything
yeah okay
do you can you get one more
I can sure try
I think you can and here's the deal or
maybe two more and let them know I'm
starting a text thread because I'm going
insane
because I have five kids under six and
so I'm gonna text y'all when I have a
question about something or when I
um feel like shaving my head just to see
what I look like without any hair like
whatever is hap like
they the people will be honored to be on
the other end of that text message okay
and it would be really gangster if you
got together once a week just to have
nachos and be like whoa
okay you're not abandoning your kids if
you do something with other people once
like you know on some interval once a
week or something like that in fact it'd
be a gift to them and it'd be a gift to
you yeah
cool
awesome thank you so much I I keep I'm
like I want to say I'm sorry but I'm not
sorry I'm super excited for you
but I just know I am so grateful thank
you I really um respect your show and
what you do well well I appreciate you
I've I I can tell you I really respect
you my gosh y'all are in it in it to win
it
um yeah reimagine your life
everything's different now reimagine it
and that should be a fun and exciting
exercise it'll be filled with grief and
be filled with some I'm bummed out
a man that's pretty awesome when you go
all right here's what it is we have
lots of diapers in the house let's make
this work not only let's just make this
work let's make this incredible we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor betterhelp hey
look there's a lot of things we don't
get to choose on this wild ride called
life right the neighbor's kid learning
to play Trombone weird things trending
on the tick tocks or whatever that is we
don't get to choose the weather but when
you realize how much you do have a
choice in it's so empowering check this
out you get to decide who you want to be
I get to ask myself the question who do
I want to be you get to choose who
speaks into your life and you get to
choose to pursue meaningful
relationships this is life changing
stuff but I'll be honest it's not easy
these are new skills that we all have to
learn and therapy is a great place to
practice these new skills and that's why
I love better help better help is
Affordable online therapy that can match
you with a therapist quickly and it lets
you switch any time to make sure it's
the right fit and just like in-person
therapy it can help equip you with the
tools you need to work towards being who
you want to be because you don't just
have to let life happen to you you can
take it head on so visit betterhelp.com
deloney today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to
Christian Sister Christian in Kansas
City Missouri what's up
hey Dr John how are you partying dude
what are you doing
uh not a whole lot it's Friday so
enjoying that
nice nice risk 28 degrees I think so
that's fun risk 28 degrees if it got to
be 28 degrees in Tennessee they'd shut
the state down so what's up man
uh first I was going to say thank you
for all that you all do y'all are great
um really helps uh listen to you guys
I've extrapolated a lot
um and put into practice on what you
teach and advise and it's made a
difference I appreciate it um thank you
thank you for listening dude in Our Gang
yeah and I also I know you're from Texas
but open invitation if you ever want
some real barbecue head on over to Casey
we'll hook you up all right fighting
words and I've had barbecue in Kansas
City and it is incredible I've got
family in Kansas I love it it's
incredible awesome um yes very well done
very well done
so I wanted to call and talk to you
about something I think I've kind of
combated most of my adult life
um it's a
the one one phrase I guess is the inner
critic but the more ominous title is
imposter syndrome okay so I
um what kind of brought it up was one of
your callers I listened to not too long
ago was a young gentleman that was
um he'd get burnt out really quick on a
job and switch to a new one every
several months or so and then after that
I was just like you know what I need I
need to call Dr John so
um I'm actually taking a new position
um at the start of the year
really excited about it
um but then here come all these feelings
of are they going to find out that I'm
not the right one do I know enough do am
I smart enough will I contribute enough
like all of these things that are
telling me that
I don't measure up okay
um and when I was starting to write some
of this stuff down to kind of keep my
thoughts in order I was like you know I
think I've dealt with this for a long
time it just manifests in different ways
um like one example would be when I was
going through undergrad
um when I would you know write all these
down and you know demand evidence from
them as you would say
um graduated with honors uh 3.8 even GPA
so it did really well but the entire
time I was just like is this is this
major for me like am I smart enough to
do this for for my life you know it was
um who taught you
that your thoughts about yourself didn't
count as much as somebody else's
um
just home
um so like in the about me stuff
um
I had a pretty strict upbringing I would
say
um I know my parents probably had the
best intentions sure but it was the way
I absorbed it and the way I've kind of
been brought up to think about myself
was you know minimizing pretty much
everything so so there's a pretty strict
Church oh so go ahead I was gonna say
there's
um
there's some pretty compelling research
about strictness
and strictness void of relationship
creates very anxious uncertain kids
yeah because there's a message of
strictness if you will
um
that ultimately says you cannot be
trusted
and there's some truth to that you're a
child of course you can't be trusted
right but there's this it's the air you
breathe your thoughts are stupid what
you think you want to do is stupid the
things that you think are going to make
you feel good are stupid you want to be
in relationships stupid and it's just
this it's this it becomes your heartbeat
there is some power to very strict
parents who also have very deep
relationships with their kids that's
what I'm aiming for I'm a strict dad
um like let's take video games I talk
about that a lot I'm very strict when it
comes to video games and
I also know that because I've said no
over here means I have to be very open
to doing things with my kids because
I've taken this option off the table for
them which means we've got to spend time
together which means you gotta kick a
soccer ball which means I have tons of
opportunity to tell my kids how that I'm
proud of them that they're doing good
work we laugh together they get to see
that they can make their old man laugh
right or they're faster than me or
whatever the thing is and so the
strictness is in combination with
relationship and that is the quadrant
I'm aiming for but if you grew up in a
home that was just you know why we don't
do this because we don't want to burn in
hell and you're dumb right that is so
accuracy not a conducive way to create
an adult who feels certain about
anything right yeah other than your own
demise right oh my gosh yeah so yeah
that was yeah we went to you know church
every Wednesday sometimes you know
multiple times twice on Sundays of
course I was a norm uh dad was in law
enforcement so it was always like it's
like my same house behavior and
perception weren't everywhere not
misbehave because then I look like I
can't control my kids or we get nasty
looks at church or all those things and
if he's in law enforcement it's you
can't misbehave because
if you hold hands with that girl that's
gonna lead you to dancing and if you
dance that's going to lead you to
smoking cigarettes and if you smoke
cigarettes You're a murderer right right
and that's that's what law I mean that's
the world right that's their world yeah
and so um everything's a gateway drug so
all I have to say is this
um
I want to back out and just teach on
this for a second is that cool I'm going
to use you as a proxy so okay your brain
is always scanning 24 7 365 asking and
again I'm I'm way oversimplifying this
but it's always asking am I safe
do I belong where is my tribe right so
am I safe here do I have a tribe do I
have a gang and does this feel good the
opposite being
am I in pain right and it's scanning all
the time for these questions and if you
find yourself in a new environment
are they paying you more money by the
way
uh it'll be the same pay but
um like right now I'm working from home
and I think part of my issue is just
where I left I had a really great
relationship and I don't like I'm you
know pretty isolated
um just really hard to get any sort of
meaningful interaction so right this
place will have some some interaction
this will be like a hybrid thing so very
cool so so this idea of am I going to
belong here
and so your body's already spinning like
man I don't know about this and then the
safety what if they meet me and they
don't like me and if they don't like me
I'm gonna get fired if I get fired and
and I'm not like man this is a gift that
people who work in law enforcement give
their kids but it also turns into a
curse of an adult
you are trained as the child of somebody
in law enforcement
to think 17 steps down the road
and you very quickly I'm guessing can go
from
what if I don't know enough to I'm
homeless and destitute and my family
fear catastrophizing is one of my
go-to's well hey it's because our dads
my dad's the same that guy loved me like
crazy and all day every day he dealt
with murder
and so
he knew the steps to not get murdered
and that was right imposed on like on as
a kid and so man everything was done out
of love
and also it made for an insecure adult
like I don't know what I don't know how
to walk I don't know what to do there's
murderers everywhere right and it's just
spinning so
um Claire Joseph has a couple of great
definitions of imposter syndrome one is
imposter syndrome is the gap between how
you currently see yourself as being and
who you think you need to be
and for your whole life somebody has
been telling you who you need to be
and instead of teaching you how to ask
yourself that question
okay that's number one number two is
imposter syndrome is the fear of others
judging you the same way you judge
yourself
and you are not nice to Christian are
you not at all because Christian sucks
and he's never doing it right and he's
always gonna come on come on Christian
oh now he's going to hell got it right
there's no way there's no way for
Christian to win
and so you spend a ton of time
thinking about Christian and how is
Christian going to keep safe and I won't
put you on the spot but I often see
folks who are
um world class I'll say this nicely I
won't say Liars but exaggerators
they're able to get in and out of social
situations or work situations
and they're able to navigate this and
navigate this because they've been
practicing it since they were a kid
they're very very skilled at it and then
all of a sudden they find themselves in
a professional position
and they have either said they could or
demonstrated or kind of around the edges
given the impression that you can do
this job cool you're hired and then it
goes oh no yeah yeah right
you're talking to a guy that hired a an
accounting student
that to come into my office he sneak
into my office
and he taught me how to use Excel when I
was running multi-million dollar budgets
because I didn't know how
right I had to go get extra training
from a student who was paying me tuition
dollars
so that I could do my job
right and so
[Music]
yeah
let me just say this ask you this are
you a fraud are you a fake
no you're not I know you're not no okay
so self-doubt is about what you know you
can do and can't do self-doubt is about
skills all right if you don't have
self-doubt you know what you can do and
you know what you can't do imposterone
imposter syndrome is not about what you
think you can or can't do
it's about who you think you are
and that's a huge difference that you
don't belong that you're never going to
be enough that you're going to get fired
that you're going to screw this thing up
you're not going to fit in at this new
job what right it's a feeling in your
body that you don't belong in this job
or you don't belong in this room or you
don't belong in this marriage that's
imposter syndrome
okay and so I'll ask you so so solving
this problem let me say this solving
this problem isn't about
trying to get new skills
it might you might need to learn some
stuff in your job in fact I would hate
it for you if you took a new job and you
don't have anything to learn that would
be a lame existence hopefully you have
tons of new things to learn right yeah
yeah it'll be plenty to learn for sure
yeah
going into a situation and not knowing
things is only bad when you've lied
about what you know if you've
misrepresented yourself if you haven't
done that then going into a situation
and not knowing what to do next is
called being a human
you've heard me on this show say I don't
know when somebody calls me with their
problem or I've been pretty open about
the number of times I call an expert
like Dr Lynn Jennings or Dr Michael
Gomez or Dr Lane Norton I called him and
asked them hey I'm getting this I'm
having a call today on the show I don't
have any experience with this walk me
through what uh what you would do
because you're an expert in this thing
like that's just that's being a normal
human being
and so that comes down the cool thing is
getting over imposter syndrome is an
internal thing it's not an external
thing you see what I'm saying
so yeah go ahead I stopped throwing a
lot what do you think that's okay no
that makes so much sense because like
growing up like I have like one of the
phrases I heard repeated a lot was you
have so much potential why aren't you
doing
X Y or Z like why are you only getting a
b like why why aren't you doing this
homework like why aren't you whatever or
when I would even younger when I would
be upset or something I got uh I'll give
you something to cry about like there
was there was no physical abuse but
there was that threat that whatever
you're upset about is not worth what
you're like the energy or effort you're
putting and I mean granted I was
probably young and I wanted a toy that
couldn't you know I couldn't have it or
whatever but you know growing up when
that's all you hear right am I even so
you just you just nailed imposter
syndrome
number one the the Finish Line always
moved on you
yeah hey dude I got all these in a b you
couldn't have got one more B one more a
really
yeah you know like seriously is that who
you are you're just always and a b kind
of guy
and so right so you go home and you have
this like I did it I got I got always
gonna be and then the finish line moves
and then you would have got straight A's
and it's like
one of these is at 90. you barely made
it
and then all right so the finish line
moves again and then at the same time
you're being told on repeat you cannot
trust your feelings bam I hit my head oh
that hurts no it didn't I'll give you
something to cry about right and it's
this it's this it's it's like
um it's like uh like an hourglass right
with the sand like just
slowly draining out of out of it
that's what happened to your ability to
trust yourself
and so what you have to practice moving
forward is how do I trust Christian
again no not again how do I trust
Christian period
and here's the way I've had to learn to
trust myself
I hold two things in in one in one hand
and one in the other
in my left hand I hold bad things could
happen I could get fired
I can get hit by a dump truck
and so I'm gonna make sure I've got life
insurance so my family's taken care of
and I'm going to make sure I'm really
good when I show up at work
I hold that very Loosely what I hold
relatively tightly and the other hand is
it's probably not going to happen
does that make sense so I give myself
Grace I make room for
uh maybe this isn't as big a deal as
your as your body's making it out to be
maybe it's not so let's don't respond to
an email for 24 hours
on the other side of it is hey my body's
telling me this is a huge deal it might
be so in 24 hours I'm going to
re-examine this I'm just going to learn
to trust myself over time
and when my body starts to feel like I
don't belong in a room like I'm an
imposter like I'm fake like I'm ah
I just smile
and then I'm curious what are you trying
to protect me from
because I know this here's here's the
thing that happened we got I got a call
out of the blue I'm getting on an
airplane I got a call out of the blue
hey Jordan Peterson's team just reached
out to you
um would you would you be on his show
tomorrow morning in Los Angeles
um
I was like okay and then I thought oh
man that guy's real real real smart and
we don't agree on everything
and he is a controver he loves Contra
what if I end up getting dragged into
deep water and he's smarter than me and
we head off into the like he's a union
psychologist and I'm not in fact dude I
started going and then it ended up with
who do you think you've already be
sitting at this table
and then I started smiling I was like oh
I know you're protecting me from
embarrassment getting canceled looking
dumb right and then I worked myself back
dude I've worked in colleges for years
I've been with faculty members who are
brilliant and have wonderful minds and
interesting perspectives and that's my
so I was able to just demand evidence
from it and reverse engineer it to I'm
just gonna have a great conversation and
if I look dumb my wife still likes me on
most days my kids love me right and I
can go back to being high school
basketball coach I love I was good at
that and so I was able to
land in a place where I could have a
good conversation and now they're that
particular episode's got millions and
millions of views because it was it
wasn't a and I found also Dr Peterson be
a lovely human being like off air he was
a great great guy so all that to say is
no matter how good you think you are
I've got two phds I've got all this
stuff I've got a number one best-selling
but my first thought was you don't
belong at that table who do you think
you are right it still happens and then
I'm just going to work through my
process I'm gonna be curious about what
my body's trying to protect me from am I
safe do I belong here and does this feel
good I'm gonna be Off to the Races is
that cool
yeah cool My Hope for you is you you
begin to trust yourself as much as your
employer trusts you
are you married
yep does your wife trust you
yep
no question are you worthy of her trust
do you lie to her a lot
no you cheat on her
nope okay
so
your wife who you love and Trust has
said I trust you
a a for-profit company who can only stay
open if they make money has picked you
as the best person to lead that
organization in that particular area
they hired you to help them serve people
so that they can make money to stay open
they picked you
so it sounds like the only person who
doesn't trust Christian in this equation
is Christian
and maybe Christian's family who again
loved you deeply in an effort to keep
you safe ended up robbing you of the
ability to walk on your own two feet and
so your life mission
for the next five years ten years is
learning to trust Christian learning to
trust your feelings learning when to
know when when your feelings are
bananas out to lunch they're way off
um
learning when to make the next right
move
learning when hey this is something I
should really be scared about or uh it's
just my body being anxious again
you're going to practice those things
write them down write them down write
them down write them down
check in with your wife
chances are she's tired of Christian
talking to her husband the way you talk
to you
because she loves you but remember
self-doubt is about what you can and
can't do you don't have that
imposter syndrome is who do you think
you are to even be in this room and my
hope is over time with practice and with
intentionality you can lean back and
throw your shoulders back and say I'm
Christian
and I've earned the right to sit at this
table
your move man
congratulations on your new job you're
gonna do awesome we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the homebuyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back and um it's time
for another installment of facts are
your friends
to something
get out your Marlboro Reds and your bush
tall boys
now don't get any of that stuff out
it'll just make you feel bad tomorrow
I'll make it it'll make you feel bad
right now all right so facts of your
friends I'm doing a hostile takeover of
facts of your friends today sorry Kelly
Shake It Off
um James sent me James child's the old
producer of the show that Kelly like
dude it was Hunger Games and she got rid
of him hostile takeover is dope
um he forwarded me an email the other
day
um he's still employed he's got a job
he's doing fine
this is incredible listen to this
a lawsuit has been filed in Canada this
is from Fox News
a lawsuit has been filed in Canada by
parents who say their kids are addicted
to the video game fortnite
a Canadian Supreme Court Judge
authorized a filing by Quebec parents
against their manufacturer parents say
their kids are addicted so so addicted
that they don't take care of regular
everyday hygiene such as showering
some kids are so dependent on fortnite
they stopped eating and sleeping
according to BBC News and reported by
Insider
this gives me hemorrhoids at a level
that preparation age simply can't help
it's fun it's
phenomenal to me that this is a thing
happening on the planet right now this
is happening on the planet right this
second
um the attorney who brought the suit
equated the games maker the people who
created and produced fortnite with
tobacco manufacturing let's let's plan
apart for a second because that's stupid
and you've heard me on this show I think
the people behind big tobacco were evil
people behind some of the big food
companies aren't evil because they're
taking
products and they are hiding
uh number one they're taking products
that they are handing to adults
and who then hand them to their children
and they say hey we've done all the
testing on these These are super safe
and not only are they safe look at our
package they're good for you they help
out with things if you go back to the
original cigarette manufacturers
cigarettes were something that helped
calm you down it helped it menthol
cigarettes cigarettes were good for
pregnant women right this is nonsense
like that and so when they got the
reports that hey everyone's getting
cancer and dying they hid those reports
and they lied about them that's evil
you also have heard me say I think video
games are a Scourge on Humanity I don't
like them I do know a lot of people that
play and they're great human beings and
I actually like playing Mike Tyson's
punch out still the greatest game ever
and Metroid from the original Nintendo
legit game
um
and I might get my kids a system at some
point fine
but here's the deal
I'm the parent
and if my 12 year old is so focused on a
particular thing carrots Pizza
cigarettes a video game I'm the parent
it's my job to intervene and if that
means smashing the video game systems
and cutting all the chords to the Wi-Fi
to the to the high-speed internet coming
into my home then that's what I do
because I'm a parent
I am Mom and Dad
cut the cord I also know that if I cut
the cord that means I got to do more
parenty things
that are really annoying and that hurt
because I'm tired I'm exhausted
but the idea that I just can't control
what's in my house and I just don't know
I'll be my kids no
parents here's the dopest thing about
Electronics
and I didn't know this there's a button
on the side and it says off and you can
just push it and it goes off it turns
off
you can take the controllers and set
them on fire making it impossible to
play
I don't for a second believe that
fortnite or whatever video games are not
addictive I'm confident they are I bet
we could do a deep dive into some of the
literature that they have some of the
studies they've done on how to get kids
to play more how to get people playing
these games to play them more often with
different fonts and different lights and
withholding things in certain intervals
I'm confident that exists
but I'm more confident that it's the
parents responsibility to keep their
kids safe and if your kid is unable to
shower or eat or sleep
because they're so entrenched in a thing
as a parent it's your job
to intervene to keep your kids safe and
intervention is not lobbying grenades at
some video game maker they're doing
their job quite frankly their job is to
get you to play more of their product
cool
cool here's what I love
um they go the the the the makers of the
game go on to say parents can receive
playtime reports that track the amount
of time their child plays each week and
they can require parental permission
before purchases are made in the game
so the company's not saying hey play
less they they can't say that because
that's their they lose their job but
they're saying hey parents we've even
built in ways for you to participate in
this
foreign
at some point at some point
moms and dads we've got to step up and
step into these situations
and stop completely abdicating
responsibility to raising her kids to
third-party people
whether it's a video game or a school or
a youth group or a church whatever I've
got to be present in my kids lives
and if your kids want to play I don't
know what fortnite is I don't know
anything about it but if they want to
play it knock your lights out I don't
know maybe is it is it unhealthy game is
it a bad game for kids
no it's one it actually is one of the
ones my son used to play it he doesn't
anymore but it requires some thought
process and you have to knock your
lights out great great
um yes play play video game is fine
but it's up to you as the parent to
regulate it and how much time they're
spending on it and who they're
participating with and are they being
groomed for in-person encounters by
people that you don't want your kids
around that's your job it's your job I
also want a shout out if you're a single
single mom or a single dad and you're
working four jobs
and this is a way for you to breathe I
get that man I get that's hard
like hey my kid there's an overlap
between my work shifts my kid goes home
he plays fortnite for a few hours and
that gives me that gives me a gap
and cover I get it I get it
I'm gonna ask you to reconsider
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you to reconsider using
digital babysitters as a proxy for
Parental intervention or as a less risky
Endeavor than
a number of other behaviors we can put
in front of our kids
I guess what I'm asking for is let's
stop blaming people
I'm gonna start taking responsibility
for the children inside our homes
and that starts with
using the off button starts with saying
no it starts with telling our kids you
can't do that because it's not safe it's
not good for you
that's what parenting is
that's what parenting is we'll be right
back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
as we wrap up today's show I guess
because the the caller's name with
Christian
you actually do love this band
I'd legit do I'm not gonna lie
this tattoo is an Old English across
Kelly's stomach I've never seen it she
just talks about a lot night Ranger's
sister Christian and it goes like this
Sister Christian all the time has come
you know that you're the only one to say
okay
where are you going what are you looking
for you know those boys don't want to
play no more with you it's true you're
motoring what's your price for flight in
finding Mr Right
you'll be all right tonight I don't even
know what that means that sounds like
the Cat in the Hat green I do not like
green eggs and ham Sister Christian
but I do like you we'll see you soon